This isn't dough, it's ice cream.
And yet it's chewy, stretchy, doesn't melt like regular ice cream...
...and it's often cut with a butcher's knife instead of scooped.
It's called maras dondurma and it's an old family tradition here in Turkey.
Located at the foot of the Ahir mountains, Kahramanmaras is Turkey's ice cream capital.
Attila's family business is one of the largest operations in the country.
Maras ice cream has three main ingredients...
...that contribute to its distinguishing features and taste.
The first is the milk.
The second ingredient is the sweetener.
But the third ingredient is where the real magic happens.
In addition to the salep, hand churning the ice cream is crucial.